the man who has been part of football
night in America since 2009 is Tony
Dungy back here on the program how are
you Tony hey rich doing well and you
kind of scare me with that it is hard to
imagine this is our 11th year football
night so guys it's been fun though
you're deep into your second decade as a
television broadcaster people out there
little kids now so did you just coach I
just thought you're on TV just like with
John Madden idea that's right yeah they
just yeah I've heard of that Madden guy
because they play his video game like no
no no no no I have to stop them just say
no no let me sit down let me tell you a
story about John man oh man when was the
last time you got a call though from
somebody knocking on your door to check
on you a little while ago my first few
years I been like I did two calls every
every year and then God's when I think
when the lion Martin made you was doing
a search and he asked me about a couple
names and he said let me before we go on
just would you have any interest in
gossip you know that was my dad's
favorite team and I grew up there and
Martin if my dad was still alive maybe
but that was kind of the last real
serious one and that was several years
ago so would you say it's totally out of
your blood coach oh yeah yeah no
definitely I'm enjoying life now and
love what I do and it had a great 28
years of coaching but there's none in
the future that's for sure 28 years huh
yeah what what yeah what do you miss the
most about coaching then you know I
think I missed that be this time of year
I miss going into training camp and
having 80 guys who you're trying to get
the message to and you're trying to just
develop this unit that you're going to
cut down to 53 but you're going to have
everybody on board
doing the same thing competing for one
common goal and fin if you can get there
that time was always special to me when
you'd say hey I think we're going to be
pretty good this year I see that I had
the tiger in this group but those were
fun times and what don't you miss
I guess I don't miss the fact that when
I was coaching you never had time that
you could really dedicate to yourself
and your family it wasn't that it was
pressurized or you spent too much time
there because I didn't spend an over
amount of time at the office but the
fact that hey my daughter's birthday is
the 7th of September and it doesn't
matter I know I'm gonna miss her
birthday party because we're either
gonna have a practice or a game and
there's nothing I can do about it and
that not having that flexibility in your
schedule was tough not bad Tony Dungy
Pro Football Hall of Famer here on the
Rich Eisen show what do you think Frank
Reich went through when he heard Andrew
Luck look him in the eye or saw Andrew
Luck look him in the eye and say no I am
NOT playing football anymore you know
rich it's crazy I was actually there two
Thursday's ago right before all this
broke they had Alumni Day and I'm at
training camp
a lot of our players are there Peyton's
there I talked to Andrew for five
minutes he all he's talking about is
getting ready and getting back in the
lineup he talked to Peyton for 30
minutes about you know how he did it
post injury and all those things so
never thought of that now Frank
he understood hey it might be week one
it might be week three we've got to get
Jacoby ready
you know until Andrews back so he was
kind of going through it on a short-term
basis maybe I've got to go a week maybe
it's a month but I'm sure it was just
incredible and hard to believe when
Andrew says I think I'm done because no
one saw that coming I mean I I just I
couldn't fathom it when it happened so
not even a single hint of it and and and
so many fans Tony you know I think this
might be the last week that we do
discuss it because next week it's gonna
be football time football season rubber
meeting road finally but while I have
you here it's just difficult for fans to
fathom that he would go from say two
weeks before talking to you talking to
Peyton and not not in a week a today you
know are you serious okay to Thursday
before it happened
so he retired on a Saturday and he's
talking to you and Peyton I thought you
said two week two days before no the
Thursday before it happened he's out
there throwing like a maniac throwing
bullets a hundred miles an hour doing
all these footwork drills with the rehab
people he's talking about gosh I'm so
frustrated I can't get out there with my
guys
but I will say this it wasn't a snap
decision this was a long-term thing in
his mind and I know he wanted to be back
a hundred percent the thing that
frustrated him and what Frank told me
that was so frustrating the doctors are
saying we don't see what's causing this
pain you should be better than this now
you shouldn't be feeling any pain and he
was so I'm sure in his mind am I ever
going to get back to full strength am I
ever going to be a hundred percent but I
can sympathize with that because coach
Noll who coached me he always used to
say that this is a game for the
committed and if there's any doubt in
your mind that you want to be out there
you shouldn't be out there because it
takes everything in you to give your
team what you need to give them and I
think that's where Andrew was if I can't
give them my best then I don't want to
be out there Tony Dungy pro Football
Hall of Famer here on the Rich Eisen
show so last thing for you on this have
you spoken to Reich and/or Irsay or
anybody else in the organization since I
haven't spoken to them since it took
place but I'll tell you Frank is the
perfect guy for this situation he was in
that role as a backup quarterback for a
long time he had to come in in certain
spots for Jim Kelly and when he came in
the game plan was a little bit different
it was tailored to what he could do well
but he had most confidence in himself
his team had confidence in him and when
he went in they played well and I know
that's what he's going to get across the
team hey we'll do things a little bit
different for Jacoby but we feel good
about the game plan we've got for him
and he is a good player and this is his
time to step up and shine and lead so
Frank had been been in that situation
he'll handle it well and I can tell you
this the team does have confidence in
Chico nope no doubt about it
and the line is terrific the defense is
ready to
they've got skilled position players all
over the map Tony before you you joined
in the first out of the show I chose the
Colts to win the division I still think
they win this division Tony what I think
they will and Jacoby the thing people
have to understand this was an Andrew
Luck practicing playing and then one day
decided to retire a week before the
season started Jacoby burr said has been
the number one quarterback ever since
the first day of OTAs so he's gotten all
the work
everything's been tailored to him and in
Frank Reich's mind it was when do I go
back to the Andrew Luck game plan but
for for 20 weeks now they've been in the
jacobi percent game plan so I think that
that's gonna be a benefit to them also
earlier I chose as as my MVP Patrick
mahomes and back-to-back years Tony wow
I know that's a that is a while but I
really think that the kid is that
talented and that good that what we saw
last year was not an outlier and that he
is in the hands of Andy Reed and that
offense ready to roll again barring
injury I wonder what you think about
that and if if not him then who well he
is special and I'll tell you I was so
impressed with him last year it's not
the 50 touchdowns not all the great
throws but processing the offense and
Andy didn't hold things back he didn't
say this is the first year starter so
I'm only going to put in 80% of my stuff
I mean they were doing different things
weekend and week out he was processing
at time school point in the game all of
those things like a veteran so I'm with
you
I thought maybe not having Kareem hunt
who was so strong in the running game
that may be a factor but they've got all
that weaponry back and Andy Reed knows
how to get the most out of quarterback
so I see another unless there's an
injury I see a forty five touchdown
passes and again yeah and then that
would make them an MVP candidate for
sure so then if not him then who would
who do you think has an MVP type
campaign
in him ready don't be on court you know
if you told me to pick Patrick mahomes
or any other individual I'd go with
Patrick you know you have to throw into
the tom brady's gosh
who else could you know give you that
type of year well I mean you've got
maybe Jared golf sure he's got once
being mentioned quite a bit Tony because
of but he's got to stay healthy he's got
to play a full year and and that right
now there's a question mark if he does I
think he's going to play great ball I
think Philadelphia is going to have a
good team but it's almost in this day
and age it's almost certainly going to
be a quarterback and it's going to be a
quarterback off a team that wins the
division so those are the guys you have
to look at do you think the Cowboys need
Zeke week one period to win a Super Bowl
this year Tony I don't think they do I
think they could win it without him
being there all the time but I think
when you get to the playoffs he's got to
be up and running and ready to go I
think they can compete they can get in
the playoffs even if he's not there the
whole time but I don't think they could
go those four weeks against the top
teams without him ok and then your Super
Bowl prediction that I'm sure you'll be
asked for your in America next week know
what I honestly rich don't have one yet
B I'm so disappointed in watching this
preseason I don't know who's gonna be
good and who is I haven't seen enough
real football from anybody to say oh
yeah like where they are so I'm gonna
have to wait I'm gonna talk to you in
two weeks
ok well I think that's the way the world
now though Tony I don't think you're
gonna see you're not gonna see any real
preseason football maybe ever again I
don't think and maybe that's ok with the
way offseason programs are now in these
OTAs and everything maybe we don't need
it and we should do away with it but
I'll tell you I have not been able to
glean anything from this preseason so
far I agree I haven't either
that's why I'm you know I'm sitting here
thinking MVP I gotta go with the guy the
kid last year who is yeah whose window I
think is just beginning to crack even
and then division winners you know I'm
trying to swap a swap a few oh it's very
different
to get there to get there and that's in
the predicting business I wonder what is
it like in the coaching business do you
think you know you know you can tell by
the way your team is practicing you know
how they're going to be I saw the
Cleveland Browns I was up there in
Indianapolis and they were working
against the Browns and you know I've
heard all this hype about Cleveland and
you could see the talent level I mean I
watched a Baker Mayfield and I was
impressed as those wide receivers are
special they've got some guys on defense
who can bring it so you know you see all
that and you say yeah there there are
pieces for the puzzle here that look
very good but what is going to happen
when you get that injury when you face a
little adversity when you miss a field
goal to win a game how is this group
going to respond to adversity and that's
what we don't know and if do you ever
had somebody that's come up to you and
say I'm not playing without my helmet
that I like so much that would be a new
one you know everybody's got something
that helps them tick and you know we had
guys ahead their favorite shoulder pads
and their favorite helmet and their
favorite shoes and it's you know all of
that but you know would have to trigger
to you and I used to say it all the time
when our personnel people would come to
me so-and-so they want to give us this
player and he's great and I would say
okay why are they trying to help us this
player is so good why are they giving
him to us and what's the catch and to me
that that had if you're the Oakland
Raiders you have to think that here's a
man who catches a hundred balls every
year he goes for 14 to 18 hundred yards
and he scores 15 touchdowns every year
why are they giving him to us and maybe
it comes with a low buyer beware a
couple more minutes left with Tony Dungy
not only Pro Football Hall of Famer but
spokesman for the fatherhood program all
pro dad and you're here to not just talk
about that but also are you promoting a
movie Tony you have a movie well we're
teaming up there's a movie called
overcomer it's a great movie about a
high school coach he's in a small town
and loves basketball that's his thing
and his team gets gutted because the
number one employer in town moves out he
loses all his kids they lose a lot of
enrollment and he ends up having to
coach
cross-country and he coaches the girls
cross-country team and so his identity
goes from hey I'm the state championship
caliber basketball coach to I've got to
do something I don't even know I can do
and it's just a great lesson for men and
that's why our fatherhood program is
teaming up with it that hey we don't
want to be identified by what we do we
want to be identified by who we help and
how we do things
so it's overcomer which is in theaters
right now was released last week okay
and and so this is something that you
hooked up with were you did you walk a
red carpet for this Tony did you I did
not but no all throw dead the you know
charity that I work with we've kind of
teamed up with the overcomer project and
the Kendricks brothers have put out a
bunch of films like this war room and
this is just the latest one it's really
special and we're just encouraging men
to take it in and and see what they can
learn from it yeah hosting experiences
for dads and kids at NFL and college
football stadiums connecting families
with children who need fostering or
adopting that's the All Pro dad program
an overcomer again in theaters right now
is released last week the sixth film
from the Kendrick brothers yeah Tony
have a great season are you go you're
going to will you be in Chicago we will
I'm actually even Tuesday I might have
to get out a little earlier depending on
what they're in for this weather down
here in Florida but yet we are will be
there Thursday night looking forward to
kicking off the hundred season of NFL
football yeah I just had Aaron Rodgers
on and man I just I can't wait to see
Packers bears just to start this with
the new Packers offense for the first
time in over a dozen years a different
yeah a different scheme one would think
and then the Bears without Vic Fangio
wondering what the Bears defense that's
like they maybe Carli Lloyd will be
kicking field goals for him by that I
don't know it's really crazy right no it
is and I can't wait to see it to see
some real football and to answer some
question what is that offense really
going to look like is the Bears defense
going to be as good
will mr. Biscay make the next step and
you know how does this rivalry and
hundred-year celebration and Packers
Bears are we going to get an upset well
Green Bay be able to come in and
derailed as it bears early on so it's
going to be fun where it will be there
with NBC and looking forward to it Tony
be safe with the weather with you and
your family and I look forward to
chatting with you down the line in the
season sounds good Ritz in three weeks
I'll tell you who I think's going to win
the Super speak to you in three weeks
I'm gonna hold you to look for my phone
you got it same here that's Pro Football
Hall of Famer Tony Dungy at Tony Dungy
on Twitter there's an underscore in
between the names on Instagram and check
out overcomer in theaters now along with
the All Pro dad program for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app